und herren das ist hier keine
eigentliche feststunde denn es gibt
keinen festredner im eigentlichen sinne
sondern jetzt spielt hier wolf biermann
und das hat im vorfeld ja auch für viel
verärgerung gesorgt denn norbert lammert
hat ihn selbstständig ohne absprache
wohl eingeladen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr lammert freue mich dass sie bis
hierher gelockt haben
und ich alle schon weil ich sehr als
ironischer kenne das sie hoffen dass ich
den linken ein paar ohrfeigen verpasst
aber das kann ich halt nicht liefern
mein beruf war doch drachentöter ich
kann ihnen auch ihr mann mit einem
hinweis auf unsere geschäftsordnung
helfen
diese sobald sie für den deutschen
bundestag kandidieren und gewählt werden
dürfen sie hier auch reden
heute sind sie zum singen eingeladen
ja aber natürlich habe ich mir in der
ddr das reden nicht abgewöhnt und das
werde ich hier schon gar nicht
[Applaus]
ein drachentöter kann nicht eine große
gewähre die reste der drachen brut
tapfer niederschlagen
die sind geschlagen und es ist für mich
strafe genug dass sie hier sitzen müssen
dass sie das anhören müssen
und so neu bin ich nicht in der welt
wollen und ihr wollt immer das weiß ich
ja wie ihr könnt nicht aber so neu bin
ich ja nicht in der welt dass sich
einige sicht erkenne ich ja jeder
einzelne ist ein roman das muss mir
keiner breit erst erklären sehr
kompliziert aber als gruppe hier ja auch
seit seit ihr eben aus meiner sicht
keine linken gefehlt im deutschen
bundestag immer noch nie erzählen dass
eine wahl ein gottesurteil ist wenn man
die deutsche geschichte kennt seine zug
zu clever gefährlich
weiß ich doch
folge sprüche wie habt ihr drauf ich
weiß ich habe meine auch drauf wir
müssen uns gar nichts erzählen also ihr
seid dazu verurteilt das hier zu
ertragen
ich gönne es euch und ich weiß ja dass
sie die sich linken nicht links sind
auch nicht rechts sondern reaktionär
dass diejenigen die hier sitzen der
elende rest dessen sind was zum glück
überwunden ist und ich freue mich dass
ich hier ein lied singen kann
die ermutigung natürlich ihr wollten
über zerrungen werden
ich habe euch versuchen mit den liedern
als er noch an der macht war
ihr seid
[Applaus]
dieses lied dass herr lammert gerne
hören möchte und dass sich auch gerne
singe ermutigung
das sei bei dieser gelegenheit angemerkt
war bei denen die widerspruch anmeldeten
in verschiedenen gerade manche sehr
feige weil sie vermutlich manche zu
mutig war wie so ein stück seelen groth
dass sie gegessen haben dieses lied
ermutigung und ich weiß dass manche die
im gefängnis saßen wie mein freund der
pastor matthias stoff und seine frau
tine mit diesem lied in der zelle
überlebt haben und ich finde es
wunderbar dass dieses lied aus den
gefängnissen der ddr heute im parlament
der deutschen demokratie
gesungen werden kann ist das nicht toll
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du lass dich nicht verhärten
in dieser harten zeit de all zu halten
brechen die allzu schwitzend stechen und
brechen ab sofort brechen abdullah sich
nicht verbittern in dieser bitteren zeit
die herrschenden herr zittern sitz
hinter getan doch nicht vor einem
leitbild von dynamite
[Musik]
du hast dich nicht erschrecken wenn
dieser schrecken
das wollen sie doch bezwecken dass wir
die waffen strecken
schon vor dem großen streit schon vor
dem großen streit
lass dich nicht verbrauchen gebrauchen
deine zeit ans licht und tauchen sogar
aus uns und wir brauchen grad eine
heiterkeit grad eine heiterkeit
wir wollen das nicht verschreien
melina schweine zeigt das grüne licht
aus den zweigen wir wollen dass alle
zeigen dann wissen sie bescheid
das sind sie
[Musik]
wolf biermann erhält er applaus aus
allen fraktionen wohlgemerkt auch von
der linken und norbert lammert drohte
ein bisschen das ganze aus dem ruder zu
laufen den lammert hatte mit seiner
bemerkung recht eigentlich hätte wie man
hier gar kein wort ergreifen dürfen aber
jeder der ihn einlädt jeder der ihn
kennt weiß dass der haupt systemkritiker
nämlich einmal der ddr 1976 ja nicht
zurückreisen durfte aus westdeutschland
in seiner heimat dass er natürlich hier
einige worte sprechen wird über diese
rede wird noch lange geredet werden
reste der drachenboot bei allem
verständnis für die verbitterung das war
dann doch schon sehr sehr heftig
[Applaus]
ja und hinten am rand sind es vielleicht
jetzt gerade sigmar gabriel und die
bundeskanzlerin gehen zu wollen wie ihr
mann und bedanken sich bei ihm diesmal
den üblichen gratulations kuchen am
präsidenten ball lieber herr biermann
ich möchte den dank für diese ermutigung
aus gegebenem anlass mit einer
gratulation verbinden
sie feiern heute mit ihrer frau pamela
ihre silberhochzeit
in den akten denn die große
sozialistische oktoberrevolution na ja
das wird gewiss kein zufall sein dass
beides an einem datum stattfindet
[Applaus]
jedenfalls ist auch dies ein stolzes 25
jähriges jubiläum und ich vermute stark
dass sie beide heute vor 25 jahren am 7
november 1989 auch nicht vermutet hätten
dass zu diesem anlass ein frei gewähltes
deutsches parlament im reichstagsgebäude
zusammen treten würde
im namen des ganzen hauses herzliche
gratulation und alle guten wünsche für
viele glückliche gemeinsame jahre
ja meine und herren vielleicht noch eine
kleine bemerkung wolf biermann ist hier
untergebracht auf dem see soll ihr
beauftragten und dass nun die
glücklichste stuhl war für wolf jungen
ist auch nicht so ganz genau